the jurogan experience when you're
talking about china and the nba and
hollywood movies
a lot of people think of those things
those the interactions that hollywood
has
that and the nba has with china as being
insidious
they don't think it's a good thing at
all that china has that kind of an
influence
and they also think it's embarrassing
like a lot of people think that it's
embarrassing for the nba
to when the negative tweets uh
when they're in support of hong kong and
then
uh all of a sudden there was some
pushback and the nba was removed from
viewership and china and there was a lot
of sponsorships being pulled and it
became a giant issue
and then all sudden you saw the nba kind
of backtrack
and kind of kowtow and a lot of people
found that to be pretty disgusting we
don't want
the united states to ever be a country
that's doing that to china
right if china has a bunch of i don't
know what they're really into over there
ping pong players like what's their
what's their primary sport i don't know
they have a lot of basketball basketball
they like basketball
so imagine if chinese basketball becomes
super popular in the united states
and then the chinese basketball players
in the united states start talking [ __ ]
about how apple uses slave labor
and we go hey hey watch your [ __ ]
mouth bro we won't
we won't pay for your chinese basketball
anymore and then also in china backs off
like
we would think of that as being pretty
gross by the united states of
ignoring some human rights violations
or or trying to whitewash them and
trying to economically attack another
country so like
the saying that it's a positive that
china has all these people
and using as an example the fact they
strong-arm
hollywood and they strong-arm the nba
a lot of people think that's moving the
wrong direction me included like i don't
want
no i i don't think it's positive i'm
saying we need to be in a position
to level the playing field but is that
leveling the playing field or will we
just
look we're the corporations have a giant
problem with
infinite growth right yup this is a
thing that seems
completely totally preposterous but it's
the norm and the standard in the
business world
you you want your growth to increase
every year
no matter what and god knows where that
goes i'm not a mathematician or an
economist but if you
you extrapolate and keep going with that
it leads to preposterous outcomes right
that's what people would be worried
about tenfold if there's a billion
people here
they'd be like oh my god would be even
more ruthless and more cutthroat
and and more like maybe more competitive
with the rest of the world but
in what way well so here let's talk
about the china okay right so
the nba is under china's thumb because
they need
access to that market hollywood they
think they do aren't they rich as [ __ ]
so we could say right maybe we need to
have a rule that says like
well you know you you can't let the
chinese censor your [ __ ] right
yeah but this the relative size of the
markets
is going to matter right so we're we're
on spotify here right
so that's a swedish swedish company i
think um
so you know great meatballs out here
absolutely it's a lovely country right
but so
so sweden's a little country right all
their companies you know you're talking
volvo
scania spotify they're dependent on a
global marketplace
they need access right if china is the
biggest market in the world
ultimately they're going to find
themselves playing by china's rules
if america stays the biggest market in
the world then we can play by our rules
and not that we should use the the way
china does right
we shouldn't say like no nobody can say
bad stuff about america
america we've got a great tradition of
free speech here uh despite some
tensions uh it's a world difference from
china and
we carry so many other countries smaller
countries from europe
canada australia on our backs in that
regard as
creating a sort of cornerstone of
openness
as a leading market in the world that's
how it's been for so long
that people don't even think about it
but if we go into a world
where china's the number one economy but
that's the number one market where
that's what every company
cares most about china's rules then
we're going to be in trouble we're going
to be in trouble here
the swedes are going to be in trouble
and i don't think that's a world we
should look forward to
i mean i started talking about you know
china is trying to use their
their market power to sort of censor
americans
and nobody in america thinks that's good
right like there's nobody is like yeah i
think it's great that like marvel
had to take a tibetan character out of
uh
dr strange yeah isn't that crazy like
that's you know it's not the biggest
deal in the world
it is kind of a big deal though yes like
what like what
what is that right and it puts in
perspective
like what our disagreements actually
amount to
that like when you compare us to china
this is gulf right and like don't we
want to stay
number one don't we want to have the
biggest market
the biggest economy so you think that
it's
ever possible though to if we got big
enough
we could ignore the influence of china
do you think they would put that money
aside because china's always going to be
big well i don't think you ignore it
but you are able to have the upper hand
do you really think that we could ever
get to a point where marvel would say
you know what [ __ ] chyna we're putting a
tibetan guy in there
it's supposed to be tibetan why are you
in a place where you can say to them
you've got to
we don't have to make it a white woman
yeah with a bald head
let's make it a tibetan guy like it is
in the comic book i think in the comic
book it's a guy right i think so yeah
well either way it's the tibetan it's
definitely tibetan
the ancient one yeah i don't think it's
a woman either i think they went full
diversity they they
maybe it's a good move going with a bald
lady and people will say less [ __ ]
than if you go with uh i mean i think
that that's i think that that's right
you
you gender bend it so then it it's like
well
maybe you shouldn't criticize that right
because it's good but it's like no
we know what actually is motivating yeah
this
and gross and it's it sucks but do you
think we could ever get to a point where
china wouldn't have an influence because
china is still going to be a billion
people in a huge market
they're big but i think we can be number
one i mean there's beyond growth like
i think that we have to be more forceful
government-wise
in how we treat our own companies
willingness
to cater into that like i think that we
need to put some
social pressure if nothing else on
hollywood to not do that kind of thing
but see they did hedge their bets by
making a woman
it was like very clever it's a clever
little way of being a [ __ ]
um do you remember when the world health
organization there was a
a spokesperson for the world health
organization being interviewed by this
woman
and she kept asking them about taiwan
and
he hung up the phone and hung up the
show the camera and then when he came
back
on she was like so we were talking about
taiwan it's like well china's done an
amazing job
and i think we've kind of covered that
and she's like well and everybody's like
look at this
he won't even mention taiwan because
taiwan is not a recognized entity by the
people's republic of china
or whatever the [ __ ] they call them
that's the time i mean you know the who
is like a unique
uh bind in that regard but
it's you know it's troubling right like
when you see the olympics right
on nbc like the broadcast
was referring to taiwan as chinese
taipei
which was like some kind of
international yeah and you're watching
like this is bs you know like it's
fine if the ioc itself cause like you
want to have china in the olympics
it's a big country and so you know they
want to be a pain in the ass about it i
don't know maybe you got to give in but
like
an american television broadcaster
it's like have some self-respect yeah
it's called taiwan
i like i don't know yeah i don't know
what taiwan means or i was just like
that's what it's called
yeah you know i'm not going to pretend
is that amazing though they're willing
to
capitulate but that's what people do
you know it's so weird the like the
doctor strange thing is weird but
there's a lot of instances
the nba thing's weird there's so many of
these things that are weird you're like
what
really but you just realize how much
money's coming from china
yup and that you know they've worked
very hard to expand that influence and
reinforce that influence
they're very deliberate about it and i
think it's something america needs to be
more serious about you know and i think
people just like people in culture and
society
need to be more outspoken
that like you know because each little
compromise i'm sure
whoever in the script meeting was like
can we just make this a white lady
yeah i was like well what's the big deal
right well okay but we're
like completely erasing the doctors
tibetans
well also tibetan culture right you know
like
tibetan culture's not that big a deal in
the united states of course because
we're the united states but
this is one of its footprints right and
to just
snuff it out like that because of
chinese money because
you want the chinese market and like
that's
that sucks yeah there was a video about
all the different things they've done to
films
to cater to chinese markets and how
different they make these movies it's
it was really bizarre yup um would that
change at all
if there was a billion americans i mean
i think it would i think that the more
america has clout the more we can say
look you have to say no to chinese
censorship
if you want to be in the american market
i don't think that's going to be a
realistic approach
if we slip and fall further and further
behind see but they don't know that
there's chinese censorship until after
the fact we find out well doctor
strange's
mentor was actually supposed to be a
tibetan man they turned into a bald lady
well i mean
like with the movies there's a whole
process uh pen america did a good report
about this but like
where hollywood films are submitted to
the chinese censors
and you know we ought to say i mean a
whole billion thing aside like i think
we ought to say like no
like you can't you can't do that
did uh you know if the chinese don't
want to let you say
no to that didn't did tarantino say no
to the editing of scenes
i think there was a a thing they wanted
edited out it might have been about
bruce lee
because you know there's this which i
found uh distasteful
even though i'm a giant tarantino fan
his portrayal of bruce lee is just
not accurate he made him look like a
buffoon oh in uh
once upon a time in hollywood yeah i
think they resisted
the changing is that true here it is uh
tarantino
uh one of the rare directors with the
power to demand final cut on his
relatively expensive films reportedly
has no intention
of re-editing the picture not for
shannon lee not for chinese censors
squeamish about the film's graphic
violence
not for any reason yeah he refuses to
recut for the chinese market
yeah and i mean you know i don't know i
mean that that bruce lee
was not it was scroll
okay look at that the film will not be
released in china
wow he refused to edit the bruce lee c
now in order to secure a theatrical
release in china catch new episodes of
the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience